Isis did release another beheading video
this British man has to pay the price
for your promise Cameron to UM the
Peshmerga against the Islamic state
ironically he has spent a decade of his
life serving under the same royal air
force that is responsible for delivering
those arms your evil alliance with
America which continues to strike the
Muslims of Iraq and most recently from
the Haditha Dam will only accelerate
your destruction and playing the role of
the OBD lapdog Cameron will only drag
you and your people into another bloody
and unwinnable war
okay so we're obviously not going to
show it any further than that one of the
things that I think is interesting about
this is that you know this is the third
one of these videos that they released
and the first one there was tremendous
outrage second one tremendous outrage
and that's when Twitter and YouTube said
we're not going to let you post these
videos and then this one this week it
kind of went under the radar and then I
started thinking wow we reach that point
yet where even our ability to see
something really awful if we've seen it
twice already
we just can't even get upset anymore
first of all I'm still not convinced
it's not Sacha Baron Cohen but we this
is the problem with the the mass media
presentation of violence is you very
quickly become inured to it yeah
but they want it to fly into the radar
they want it to be available to be seen
because that's part of the intended
run-up to war yeah and you know there's
no reason for them not to show us unless
they want us to be outraged yeah blanket
obvious I think that we got to make a
rule though we have to stand on a moral
rule that how many of your go dings
before I just cave to your desires and I
agree we want a war because that's what
we are being herded and corralled into
the slaughterhouse mentality of we have
been corralled into it this is the
problem and equal sign only one possible
solution you
this gear we have piling up in pyramids
behind us that has nowhere to go that we
gave them and we're building for
ourselves that we are about to give them
quote unquote from the sky
and and on the ground and they're just
ramping up another excuse to go back to
the system that locks in the
infrastructure for Halliburton there
that's what this is and everything seems
like a machination in service of that
yeah so I'm glad you brought that up
because what is it about us that's what
I've been thinking since they started
what is it about us that we have to do
everything I mean look you can look at
the other countries that are really
threatened I mean people are saying well
it's an imminent threat to us I'm pretty
sure it's halfway across the world all
these guys although I know Rick Perry
thinks they're coming in from Mexico but
forgetting that I mean y-you know Turkey
has a huge border with Syria they have a
huge army shouldn't they like why are
they not doing anything why we can't get
Saudi Arabia who we give tons of money
and weapons to why is it that every time
it's like oh we have a coalition but
actually it's just that our economy is
dedicated to the manufacture and use of
military equipment and until we have an
economy that can sustain peace it makes
no sense to the to the national
zeitgeist to not be going to war all the
damn time I have this very very
controversial stance that I take on this
bring it I am opposed to very clear on
this I'm opposed to beheading people
with knives
I am also opposed to dropping bombs on
people and shooting them well what do
you want then I want I'd like to be able
to see a doctor this week because I
think I have a touch of the Ebola so
your mark we did send 3,000 troops to
Liberia to deal with that that is a good
use of these organizations that are that
can be incredibly well maneuvered and
delivered I think you know if we could
just do a shift to taking this huge
organization and really committing it to
the needs of the people of the world
right the US with its vast economic
resources and
vast willingness to be helpful in kind
could change the course of human history
in a matter of months but you know
that's not going to be a training any
money yeah don't hold your breath on
that one
so if none of these other countries are
gonna do anything and we see these
beheadings we see the awful things
they're doing to women and that Iraq and
Syria don't even exist as states anymore
and we know no one else is gonna do
anything is there any responsibility now
as the lone remaining superpower even if
we don't want war I have no I don't want
to go back there you know I mean if we
don't but is there any responsibility
before all the rest of the countries in
that area fall apart if we're the only
one that can do anything well doing here
we're back to the question of doing
anything let's list the things we can do
yeah that's really let's all establish
right now that list of when we say we're
gonna do something what that really
means what it used to mean what it
oughta mean it could mean sanctions
which if there is this unidentifiable
I am a hard to track the source is
something you don't know how to sanction
them there's then there's drone strikes
and then there's what we've no problem
doing that yeah we do that constantly
and then there's air strikes which are
manned missions you could get shot down
now you've got one of our guys then
there's a boots on the ground and that
boots on the ground and the small little
tactical strike extraction groups and
then the large rollout so those are our
options and then because diplomacy what
would diplomacy do is do they does Isis
have a list of demands that you give us
this and we'll back down or so what they
want everybody out for back down right
yeah let me point out some other options
though what if we rolled out a massive
effort to educate feed and provide
health care to the people who are so
miserable and frightened in that part of
the world that they will turn to anybody
for support what what if we were to
return profits for the oil fields to the
people who actually live on the land
where those oil fields exist so that
they could become an economic and
self-sufficient power and not feel
reliant on whoever will offer them a
handout what if we began to take actions
to solve the problems of people rather
than creating more
in a misguided attempt to protect
ourselves
yeah I mean believe me I'm on board that
crazy train I just don't know if it's
actually possible and what are the
element standing in the way of these
ideals those options you the drone
strikes and the lovitz the prophet in
there at the airstrip the need for the
resources in the area which is what it's
about you know
[Music]